Візит Зеленського до Байдена буде зовсім іншим порівняно із зустріччю з Трампом.
За словами опитаних DW американських експертів, Трамп не розумів важливості
успішної України для американських інтересів у Європі.
І його головною метою був тиск на Україну, щоб втягнути її у внутрішню політику США
і використати проти Байдена на президентських виборах.
Трампу це не вдалося. Київ спромігся уникнути чергових скандалів,
зберігши нейтралітет, відзначає Макс Бергманн,
який при Обамі працював в Держдепартаменті США.
Найголовніша відмінність між Трампом і Байденом полягає в тому,
що Трампу не можна було вірити, коли йшлося про Росію.
Було зрозуміло, що він дійсно прив'язаний до Кремля
і до Володимира Путіна, і що він прийняв тези Кремля,
коли йшлося про Україну.
Крім того, він робив спроби шантажувати Україну політично.
Я думаю, що такої корупції, яку ми бачили від нашої власної адміністрації,
від Сполучених Штатів, вже не буде.
Ми знаємо переконання президента Байдена: він буде разом з Україною
і буде протистояти Росії. Це може виглядати не завжди так, як хотілося б Україні,
Польщі чи іншим державам. Є занепокоєння щодо зустрічі з Володимиром Путіним.
Але я думаю, що слід заспокоїтися, бо Байден зустрівся з Путіним,
подивився йому у вічі та розповів про проблеми.
Україна має стати сильною і процвітаючою, а її демократія залишатися
на правильному шляху. Багато уваги буде присвячено внутрішній
ситуації в Україні - набагато більше, ніж це було за часів Трампа.
Я також вважаю, що мають бути посилені військові зобов’язання
щодо надання летальної і нелетальної зброї українській армії.
Зустріч Зеленського з Байденом має важливе символічне значення
і демонструє іншим країнам, передусім Росії,
стратегічне партнерство між Києвом та Вашингтоном.
А також готовність підтримати Київ, якщо Росія буде продовжувати
провокації чи вживати будь-які інші ворожі дії проти України.
Водночас досі незрозумілі конкретні дії США щодо "Північного потоку-2".
Минулого місяця Байден і Меркель досягли угоди для врегулювання
суперечки навколо будівництва цього газогону.
Домовленістю передбачено, що Вашингтон відмовляється від подальших санкцій,
але разом із ЄС протидіятиме Росії, якщо вона буде використовувати
газ як зброю - як інструмент енергетичного тиску, зокрема на Україну.
Ця тема буде однією з головних під час переговорів Зеленського і Байдена,
переконаний Стівен Пайфер, колишній посол США в Україні.
Президент Байден виступає проти "Північного потоку-2",
але він не був готовий запровадити санкції проти німецьких та європейських компаній,
щоб припинити його. Це спровокувало б розрив між Вашингтоном і Берліном,
а також між США і ЄС. Я був дещо розчарований,
що після зустрічі президента Байдена і канцлерки Меркель не було більше конкретики.
Які саме зобов’язання?
На що Україна може розраховувати з точки зору американської
та німецької відповіді, якщо росіяни таки використовуватимуть
"Північний потік-2" геополітично? На місці Зеленського,
я би подивився на спільну заяву, оприлюднену президентом Байденом і канцлеркою Меркель,
і спитав би: як ви на це спираєтеся?
Я не впевнений, чи вже зараз є конкретна відповідь, але питання полягає в тому,
щоб запустити процес, який би призвів до конкретної відповіді.
Другий блок переговорів - це боротьба з корупцією в Україні.
І тут вже Байден буде ставити запитання Зеленському та вимагати конкретики.
В Україні створено аж шість антикорупційних органів, які вже декілька років
працюють, але досягнення поки непереконливі.
Щоб й надалі отримувати підтримку США, потрібно демонструвати результат,
натякають у Вашингтоні. Крім того, ситуація з Афганістаном, коли за 20 років
американці вклали мільярди доларів у цю країну для боротьби з корупцією,
але це ні до чого не призвело, змушує США
переосмислювати допомогу третім країнам.
Я думаю, що Сполучені Штати продемонстрували
з 2014 року свою тверду військову прихильність Україні.
Це було і за часів адміністрації Трампа, і за часів адміністрації Обами,
коли я був ще на службі. Хоча США вже надали сотні мільйонів доларів
військової допомоги, я думаю, що це й надалі триватиме.
Боротьба з корупцією стала великим пріоритетом США.
Зважаючи на події в Афганістані, крах афганського уряду,
видно, що Сполучені Шати закривали очі на корупцію.
Тому я думаю, що це стане пріоритетом.
І якщо Україна не досягне прогресу або вважатиметься надзвичайно корумпованою,
це негативно позначиться на готовності Конгресу США
виділити мільярди доларів на підтримку України.
Водночас Стівен Пайфер вважає, що боротьба з корупцією та військова допомога -
це два різні треки, і адміністрація Байдена їх більше сприймає
як паралельні напрямки співпраці, ніж як взаємозалежні.
Україна досягла прогресу у боротьбі з корупцією, вважають експерти,
хоча ще є дуже багато проблем. Передусім, реформа судової системи
і величезний політичний та економічний вплив олігархів на державні інституції.
Сподіваюся, коли президент Зеленський приїде, у нього буде
дуже сильний меседж щодо твердості намірів вирішити ці проблеми,
а також деякі конкретні ідеї. Це сприятиме успішному візиту.
Щодо військової допомоги, то адміністрація Байдена
дала зрозуміти, що готова продовжувати надавати військову допомогу Україні.
Особливо з огляду на те, що сталося навесні, коли на кордоні з Україною
було велике накопичення російських військ, яке лише частково було скорочено,
адже поблизу України ще багато російської військової присутності.
До того ж у вересні відбудуться навчання "Захід",
які, я думаю, призведуть до збільшення російських військових маневрів
поблизу України. Можливо, настав час для того, щоб США надали
додаткову військову допомогу Україні - як з точки зору практичного внеску
в посилення обороноздатності українців, так і з точки зору надання
політичного сигналу Москві про те, що підтримка Сполученими Штатами
України залишається реальною.
Зустріч Зеленського і Байдена має відбутися 31 серпня у Вашингтоні,
якщо через події в Афганістані переговори не перенесуть.
За повідомленнями українського МЗС, афганська криза
поки не змінила плану підготовки до зустрічі.